cette initiative d'amnistié est décriée
par plusieurs organismes de défense des
droits des femmes
pour en parler je joins à québec julie
miville de chêne la présidente du
conseil du statut de la femme
vingt mille de chêne bonsoir bonsoir
c'est un sujet donc je le disais qui
divise même les féministes il ya eu des
divisions aussi à l'intérieur d'
amnistie internationale ce que vous êtes
surprise de ceux de ce vote aujourd'hui
surprise certainement et surtout déçu
parce que bien sûr on est d'accord avec
admis ch'ti sur le fait que les femmes
prostituées sont marginalisés sont
violentés et qu'il faut absolument les
aider mais là où on est vraiment pas
d'accord et nous aussi on a fait de la
recherche on a fait un avis fouillée sur
la question
c'est la solution à cette exploitation
parce que de notre côté on dit très bien
oui il faut décriminaliser les femmes et
les hommes prostitués évidemment ce sont
les victimes
mais là où vraiment on ne comprend pas
c'est qu'en misty international dit
qu'il faut aussi décliné décriminaliser
les clients et donc par le fait même
rendre la vie beaucoup plus facile aux
proxénètes et donc ça qu'est-ce qui vous
inquiète dans cette partie là la corde
et criminalise aussi pour les clients et
les proxénètes
parce que ça s'est fait dans quelques
pays en allemagne aux pays-bas notamment
exactement alors si on regarde les
résultats c'est là où ça nous inquiète
en allemagne notamment il ya 14 ans on a
légalisé la prostitution en disant que
les femmes prostituées à l'avoir de
meilleures conditions de travail
or c'est tout le contraire qui s'est
produit rien ne s'est amélioré les
tarifs se sont ont diminué donc les
conditions de travail se sont
détériorées et on a vu s'installer de
grand bordel notamment à côté de
l'aéroport de berlin où des femmes
d'europe de l'est viennent là sont sont
carrément prisonnière et vendent leurs
services pour 150 dollars à peine un
client peut passer autant de temps qu'il
le veut avec ses femmes
alors ce n'est pas une solution parce
que quand ont décriminalisé on permet
donc à l'industrie de d'exploiter encore
plus de femmes
on ouvre la voie au trafic des êtres
humains et donc tout cela n'est pas la
bonne voie mais est ce que ça peut pas
aider au moins
ils travailleuses du sexe est ce que ça
peut pas faciliter ou améliorer leurs
conditions de travail à elle un petit
peu et bien même quand il y a
criminalisation des clients on prend la
situation au canada il y à des groupes
qui travaillent dans la rue pour aider
les femmes prostituées donc ce n'est pas
le temps de décriminaliser ou de
criminaliser qui est la question mais
c'est de pouvoir aider ces femmes de
pouvoir les aider dans la rue alors nous
on est conscient qui est de la violence
dans la prostitution mais ce qu'on dit
c'est que de rendre ça banal de rendre
sa légal ça ne fait qu'augmenter les
possibilités d'exploitation de ces
femmes alors ce qu'on dit c'est ce qu'il
faut c'est rendre les clients
responsable donc les pénaliser mais il
faut aussi mettre beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent céline pour essayer de sortir
ces femmes et ces hommes prostitués de
la prostitution et c'est là que vraiment
on croit qu'une partie de la solution se
trouve
oui parce que la mission internationale
a souligné tout même c'est vraiment un
des groupes les plus marginalisés dans
la société
tout à fait et il faisait que c'est pas
simple je sais pas de vous dire que
c'est simple parce que toute la notion
de consentement et de choix est au coeur
de la réflexion d'amnesty international
et le e parle de deux adultes
consentants
alors là dessus frais nuance oui on peut
certainement dire que pour 5 à 10 % des
femmes prostituées
il y à la schl a éclairé lll choisissent
leurs clients elles sont bien rémunérés
elle ne tombe pas dans la drogue oui ça
peut arriver
paris a donc vous avez payé du monde
exactement que faire de cette masse de
femmes prostituées qu'on ne voit pas qui
vivent dans des conditions épouvantables
qui sont exploitées violenté pas payées
dont les proxénètes garde tous les
profits et ça c'est la situation la plus
connue donc c'est ces femmes là qu'il
faut aider et ce n'est pas en disant que
c'est parfaitement correcte la
prostitution que c'est un acte qui n'a
aucune conséquence finalement qu' on
pourra avancer donc oui nous sommes
déçus mais bien sûr amnistie
internationale n'est pas un gouvernement
n'est pas un état mais alors quel impact
justement ça peut avoir cette prise de
position
non c'est difficile à dire écoutez ce
que j'espère parce qu'évidemment je veux
que ces femmes là soient protégés c'est
par exemple on pourrait on pourrait
procéder à des distributions de condom
et qu'on pourrait s'occuper de la santé
de ces femmes là davantage parce que
c'est le message qu'envoie demi ch'ti
mais autrement les états chaque état se
débat avec ce problème là on le sait le
canada a adopté la voie de
décriminaliser les femmes mais pas les
clients et de notre point de vue c'est
la voie à suivre
je vais me vise la chaîne merci beaucoup
au revoir au revoir